[Music]
after the taking of babylon
darius himself marched against the
scythians
for seeing that asia abounded in men and
that he gathered from a great revenue
he became desirous of punishing the
scythians for the unprovoked wrong they
had done him when they invaded asia
and defeated those who encountered them
for the scythians as i have before shown
ruled the upper country of asia for 28
years
they invaded asia in their pursuit of
the sumerians and made an end of the
power of the medes
who were the rulers of asia before the
coming of the scythians
the scythians say that their nation is
the youngest in the world
to the tradition wherever i myself to
especially incline
it is to this purpose the nomad
scythians inhabiting
asia being hard-pressed in war by the
masajitai
fled away across the river arraxis to
the sumerian country for the country
where the scythians now inhabit is said
to have belonged of old
to the sumerians i praise not the
scythians in all respects
but in this greatest matter they have
devised that none
who attacks them can escape and none can
catch them if they desire not to be
found for when men have no established
cities or fortresses
but all the horse bearers and mounted
archers living not by
tilling the soil but by cattle rearing
and carrying their dwellings on wagons
how should these not be invincible and
unapproachable now
the scythians blind all their slaves for
they are not tillers of the soil but
wandering grazers
as to war these are their customs a
scythian drinks of the blood
of the first man whom he has overthrown
he carries to his king the heads of all
whom he has slain in battle for he
receives a share of the booty if he
brings a head
but not otherwise he scalps the head by
making a cut round the ears
then grasping the scalp and shaking the
head
out then he scrapes out the flesh with
the rib of an ox
and kneads the skin with his hands and
having made it supple he keeps it for a
napkin
fastening it to the bridle of his horse
which he himself rides
and taking pride in it for he is judged
the best man who has the most
scalp napkins there are many too that
flay the skin from the whole body
and carry it about on horseback
stretched on a wooden
frame the heads themselves not all but
of their bitterest foes they treat in
this way
if he be rich he covers the head with
the raw hide and gilds the inside of it
and so uses it for a drinking cup
moreover once in every year each
governor of a province brews a bowl of
wine in his own province
where if those scythians drink who have
slain enemies those who have not
achieved this
taste not this wine but sit apart
dishonored
this video is sponsored by the great
courses plus the premiere online
learning service
here at voices of the past we try and
cover as many different eras and
cultures as possible
and to make sure that i have a good
background knowledge to create the
videos
i use great courses plus anything that i
need to brush up on
they are the ones i turn to a great
recent example of this being the
wonderful lecture series
dark matter dark energy i won't tell you
what it's for
but get excited for something coming in
the next couple of months
and it was as simple as searching for
the thing i needed
fascinating university level stuff
ordered a very reasonable subscription
for what is essentially a mountain of
easily digestible knowledge
i honestly can't recommend it highly
enough so check them out at
thegreatcoursesplus.com
forward slash voices to get a free trial
and show your support for the channel
too i started with a free trial and
never looked back
thanks
[Music]
how many the scythians are i was not
able to learn with exactness
but the accounts which i heard
concerning their number did not
tally some saying that they are very
many and some that they are very few
counted ascitiens in this region stanza
bronze vessel
the city and bronze vessel easily
contains 5400 gallons
and it is of six fingers thickness their
king whose name was ariantis
desiring to know the numbers of the
scythians commanded every scythian to
bring him the point from an arrow
threatening all who should not do so
with death so a vast number of
arrowheads was brought
and he resolved to make and leave a
memorial out of them
and he made of these this bronze vessel
thus much i heard concerning the number
of the scythians
the burial place of their kings are in
the land of the gerai
which is the end of the navigation of
the baristanis
there whenever their king has died the
scythians dig a great
four-cornered pit in the ground when
this is ready they take up the dead man
his body enclosed in wax his belly cut
open and cleansed and filled with cut
marsh plants and frankincense and
parsley and aniseed and sewn up again
then having laid the dead in the tomb on
a couch they plant spears all round the
body
and lay across them wooden planks which
they then
roof over with hides in the open space
which is left in the tomb they bury
after strangling
one of the king's concubines his cup
bearer his cook his groom his squire
and his messenger besides horse and
first fruits of all else
and golden cups
after the burial the scythians cleanse
themself as i will show
they anoint and wash their heads as for
their bodies they set up
three poles leaning together to a point
and cover these over with woolen rugs
then in the place so enclosed the best
of their power
they make a pit in the center beneath
the poles
and the rugs and throw red hot stones
into it
they have hemp growing in their country
very like flax
this grows both of itself and also by
their sowing and of it the thracians
even make garments which are very like
linen
the scythians then take the seed of this
hemp and creeping under the rugs they
throw it on the red hot stones
and being so thrown its smolders and
sends forth so much steam
that no greek vapor bath could surpass
it
the scythians howl in joy for the vapor
bath
this serves them instead of bathing for
scarce ever do they wash their bodies
with water
but their women grind with a rough stone
cypress and cedar and frankincense wood
pouring water also there on and with the
thick stuff so ground they anoint all
their bodies and faces
whereby not only does a fragrant scent
abide upon them
but when on the second day they take off
their ointment their skin becomes clean
and shining
[Music]
as far as the country of these scythians
all the fool said land is
level and the soil is deep but
thereafter
it is stony and rough after a long
passage through this rough country
there are men inhabiting the foothills
of high mountains
who are said to be all bald from their
birth male and female alike
and snub-nosed with long beards
they speak a tongue of their own and
where city and raymond
and their fear comes from trees some
sydians make their way to them
and do their business with seven
interpreters in seven languages
but for what lies beyond the bald men
no one can speak with exact knowledge
for mountains high and
impassable by the way and no man crosses
them
these bald men say but for my part i
believe them not that the mountains are
inhabited by men
with goat's feet and the beyond these
again are men who sleep for six months
of the twelve
this i cannot accept at all for true but
the country east of the bald heads
is known for certain to be inhabited by
the isidones
although of what lies northward either
of the bald heads or the isidones we
have no knowledge
save what comes from the report of these
latter
it is said to be the custom of the
isodones that whenever a man's father
dies
all the nearest of kin bring beasts of
the flock
and having killed these and cut up the
flesh they cut up also the dead father
of their host and set out all the flesh
mingled together
for a feast as for his head they strip
it bare and cleanse and gild it
and keep it for a sacred relic for the
rest
these are said to be a law-abiding
people and the women have equal power
with the men
all this aforementioned country is
exceeding cold
for eight months of every year there is
frost unbearable
and in these you shall not make mud by
pouring out water
but by lighting a fire the sea
freezes and all the sumerian bosphorus
and the scythians dwelling this side of
the force
lead armies over the ice and drive their
wanes
across to the land of the cindy so
it is ever winter for eight months and
it is cold in that country for the four
that remain
here is a winter of a different sword
from the winters that come on other
lands
for in the season for rain therefore
scarce any
but for all the summer there is rain
unceasing and when there are
thunderstorms and other lands
here there are none but in summer
there is great plenty of them horses
have endurance to bear the city in
winter
mules and asses cannot at all bear it
butters touching the feathers where of
the syrians say the air is full
in so much that none can see or traverse
the land beyond
i hold this opinion northward of that
country snow
falls continuously though less in the
summer than in winter as is to be
expected
whoever has seen snow falling thickly
near him knows of himself my meaning
for the snow is like feathers and by
reason of the winter which is
such as i have said the parts to the
north of this continent
are uninhabited i think therefore that
in this tale of
feathers the scythians and their
neighbors do but speak
of snow in a figure thus then i have
spoken of these parts
that are said to be most distant
[Music]
the farming scythians inhabit a land
stretching eastward a three days journey
to a river called panticarpus and
northwood as far as an 11 days voyage
of the baristanese and north of these
the land is uninhabited for a long way
after which desert is the country of the
man-eaters
who are a nation by themselves and by no
means scythian
and beyond them is true desert wherein
no nation of man dwells as far as we
know
but to the east of these farming
scythians cross the river panticarpus
and you are in the land of nomads
scythians who sow nothing
nor plow and all these lands except the
woodlands are bare of trees
these nomads inhabit to the eastward a
country that stretches 14 days journey
to the river guerras across the guerras
there are lands called
royal where are the best and most in
number of the citians
who deem all other syrians their slaves
their territory stretches
southward to the toric land and eastward
to the foss that was dug by the sons of
the blind men
above the royal scythians to the north
dwell the black cloaks
who are of another and not a scythian
stock and beyond the black cloaks the
land is all marshes
and uninhabited by men so far as we know
the scythians reckoning that they were
not able by themselves to repel darius's
army in open warfare
sent messengers to their neighbors whose
kings had already met and were taking
counsel
as knowing that a great army was
marching against them
those that had so met were the kings of
the tory agathirsi
naori man-eaters black cloaks galoni
boudini
and saramate among these the torii have
the following customs
all shipwrecked men and any greeks whom
they take in their sea raiding
they sacrifice to the virgin goddess as
i will show
after the first rites of sacrifice they
smite the victim on the head with a club
according to some they then throw down
the body from a cliff
where on their temple stands and impale
the head
the tory live by plundering and war
the agathiasis live more delicately than
all the other men
and are greatly given to wearing gold
their intercourse with women is
promiscuous that so they may be brothers
and kinsfolk to each other and thus
neither envy nor hate their fellows in
the rest of their customs they are like
to the thracians
the naori follow scythian usages but one
generation before the coming of darius's
army
it fell out that they were driven from
their country by snakes
it may be that they are wizards for the
citians say that once a year
every one of the naori is turned into a
wolf
for myself i cannot believe this tale
but they tell it nevertheless
yay and swear by its truth
the man-eaters are of all men the most
savage in their manner of life
they know no justice and obey no law
they are nomads
wearing a dress like the scythian but
speaking a language of their own
they are the only people of all these
that eat
men the black cloaks all wear black
raymond
whereof they take their name their
usages arecitium
the boudini are great and numerous
nation the eyes of all of them are very
bright
and they are reddish they have a city
built of wood
concerning the hyperborean people
neither the scythians
nor any other dwellers in these lands
tell us anything
you